hello thank you all so much for being
here I know it's already the end of the
second day but on behalf of Numb focus
thank you so much for coming to PI data
London we really treasure this community
is one of the most vibrant PI data
communities and as this is the fifth
year you know that's been going on for
quite a long time so I'm going to take a
minute to tell you a little bit more
about gnome focus here is our mission
although you perhaps know us best as the
sticker people and so I want you to know
us as more than the sticker people right
we were founded at to be a foundation
that would serve as an organizing
rallying point for open source
scientific computing projects and when
you say when you hear me say projects
I'm talking about the software tools
that you all use typically everyday and
those tools are used everywhere from
Netflix to NASA to build a better world
so I know you all are tackling very cool
and interesting challenges probably on a
daily basis with these tools we have 22
sponsored projects at num focus what is
a sponsored project what I mean when I
say sponsored project essentially one of
the program's of Numb focus which is
arguably the heart of our mission is
what is called a fiscal sponsorship
program which is just fancy words that
mean a open-source project comes under
the umbrella of Numb focus and mountain
focus is the legal entity of that
project and that's valuable for a
variety of reasons
it helps projects attract funding
provides greater stability independence
and logistical support we also provide a
variety of services to the project so
you can have something like for example
numbness is the holder of a trademark
which you might not want a private
company for example to hold for an
open-source project we do all of these
wonderful things on behalf of them and
we also organize a number of programs to
grow the community so we have Google
Summer of Code this year we have 40 45 I
think students participating we have the
disc program the diversity and inclusion
and scientific computing
you can come chat
thus tomorrow at the roundtable about
that the John Hunter matplotlib summer
fellowship that is currently accepting
applications so if you are or know a
student who would be interested that's
open until May 6th I believe more
information on the website and we also
provide a number of grants and
scholarship funds and let's not forget
pi data is an educational program of
gnome focus where all over the world has
grown so quickly and I might also point
out there are 98 groups so if two people
in here want to start a group that'd be
awesome
okay I talked to Jim I'm not sure where
he has but he'd be happy to chat to you
about how to get it kicked up okay that
kicked off and so let's do the
interactive portion please raise your
hand if you use at least one of these
projects every day pandas numpy Jupiter
Ramon pileup great love it keep your
hand up if you have contributed back in
some poor fashion let's applaud these
people please thank you this this is so
incredibly important is really the heart
of what I want to talk to you about
today so this is true all over the world
there is a meaningful sustainability
challenge for these projects because
they are so great they're very very
popular if you just look at the growth
of the number of Jupiter notebooks that
were hosted on github now we're over 2
million in the course of three years
right check out the orange green and
purple lines here this is a growth in
questions asked about numpy pin as a mad
lib on Stack Overflow
so obviously lots and lots of interest
in these projects but they are not
receiving in return the kind of
resources that they need to hold up
sustainably under this demand so the
majority of the handful of maintain errs
who take care of these projects are not
even paying to work on the projects
full-time and when you think about that
it's really sort of all inspiring what
they have to hold up under so what
numbers would like is for all of us to
be able to have really stable
comfortable stream of funding coming in
to support those folks and so that's the
role of num focus
many ways is to connect these projects
with stable sources of funding PI data
is among those so for example funds that
were generated from the PI data London
conference last year helped to send some
of the project leaders to the num focus
summit in 2017 which is a gathering of
industry academic and project leaders
together to talk about the future of the
ecosystem so thank you and thank you to
Bloomberg who has been our host for a
number of years for making that possible
just to give you a sense of it because
of Pi data we have been able to bring in
more than twice as much money as what
corporate sponsors directly donate to
num focus to support the projects so
that's because your ticket is
technically a donation and all of these
wonderful sponsors have sponsored the PI
data event series and that has enabled
it to generate that funding that goes to
support the projects so what I want to
challenge you all is that if you use
these projects every day at work your
company should be a sponsor of nom focus
right so let's have some of the amazing
gains that have been achieved as a
result of using these projects go back
into supporting the projects so when you
leave the conference talk to your boss
and find out how they can get your
company to be on board as a num focus
corporate sponsor or as a sponsor of a
PI data event and in the meantime you as
an individual can contribute and many of
you have thank you so much to the
projects in a variety of ways you can
contribute code please check out the
Panda sprint tomorrow morning so cool
and exciting hopefully you heard about
the worldwide pandas documentation
sprint and there's very fantastic you
can read about it on our blog keep an
eye out for opportunities like that it's
it feels like a big jump to get into
your first open source contribution but
there are people in this community who
are there to help you make it and it's
so important you can contribute time
doesn't have to be code all the people
in orange shirts here who are
volunteering and helping to put the PI
data together is really making a great
contribution and for those of you who
would rather
for your time with money you can do that
as well we accept a donation cinema
focus that go directly to the projects
in the form of memberships and you can
find out about that more on our website
so in conclusion if you use these
projects if you love them help put them
on a sustainable path find a way to get
involved and give back so that we can
rebalance the load a little bit from
everyone using the projects but not
contributing to everyone using the
products and contributing thank you very
much
[Applause]
okay first as you might know you're a
Python it's coming to the UK this year
and we're going to this beautiful yes
and we're going to beautiful Edinburgh
as you know our PI data is strong with
your Python we have a PI data track and
you're a Python we do that together with
the local community like you know Nick
he's from the local community in Europe
- um so we a little bit late setting the
conference up because we some tax stuff
don't don't worry about it
the call for proposals will open next
week on Monday um tickets will also go
and sale soon so reserve your tails get
your budgets and just follow Europe -
one we have a difference conference
layout this year so it's not five days
of talks anymore it's only three days of
talks and the trainings are before two
days so it's a little different and yeah
so hope to see you all and you great
proposals for your saipa fr Europe - and
this brings me to the next conference
your CyHi and if you see this picture
you know you already want to go there
actually yes and the only raise it's in
northern Italy in Toronto it's the 11th
year so I applied a scientific -
conference it's the dates are from
August 28th to 1st of September
sometimes and reduce the call for
proposals is already open so see your
proposals there um and last but not
least and you always wanted to come to
Germany in October
there's the German Python conference
with
strong pilot attract if you know don't
have a herd of cows roots in southern
Germany this is where the heart of
engineering is like Bosch time their
Porsches all here so also a is strong
with us there so call for perpetuity
station will open next week and yeah I
hope to see you there and one on one
spoiler alert if you really love pandas
you should really come there and yeah
that's it thank you very much I don't
know Jim Vincent did you want to say
something as well or are we quick
mati are you in hit the Pope Wow I'm
used to being behind the scenes not in
front of the stage so this is great but
it is yeah I'm just gonna say it's a
great team and everyone because I do
email and get the privilege of slacking
and communicating with a lot of you guys
so being at the conference has been
great to actually put some faces to the
names and email addresses that I've been
with as introduction my name is Jim
Moyes I do the events coordinating and
the PI data support for numb focus I'm
the most recent addition to the team
I've been on board for about six months
now
so if we have been emailing haven't got
a chance to talk to you yet please stop
by and introduce yourself and I look
forward to doing that I guess I wanted
to come up here mostly to introduce
myself and to say that I kind of see my
job as trying to support the local PI
data communities as much as possible
because communities themselves are their
locally led they're led by people who
are volunteering their time so anything
that I can do to make your lives easier
that's what that's my goal and that's
that's what I'm trying to do and so if
there's anything we can do if there is a
community that doesn't have a PI data
presence yet and you want to be a local
leader and organizer in that you can
email me if you have a local community
that maybe does meetups and wants to
venture into doing like a day workshop
or doing a conference please email me
again if you just want some stickers you
can email me
[Music]
so yeah that that was probably my main
take-home message and just two foot
stomp some successes that we've had as
you saw we're up to 98 communities in
the world which is great and it's
continuing to grow every day so please
continue to support that flooring kind
of mentioned earlier this year numbers
are still pretty early in the in the
ball game but we're looking to maybe
bring in about 80 to $100,000 in
donations and um focus so that was
really great and appreciate you coming
and watching asset ticket and continuing
support so thank you for that and we're
trying to continue on those successes
with a couple of upcoming events which
is why I have Vincent on the stage
because PI data Amsterdam is the next
large-scale PI data conference that we
have in May from 25th to 27th so I'll
let him explain that one yeah come to my
conference okay
I also feel kind of obliged to speak on
behalf of Marty last was a little bit
crazy for me I went to like five PI data
as part of my goal was to help connect
everyone one thing I will say genuinely
this is a great conference there are
many great conferences what you will
notice if you go to all these different
PI data's they each all have a different
vibe so if you go to Berlin you know
it's very proper master that's the kind
of academic if you come to PI data
Amsterdam it's a bit more smoking a
pancake but if that sounds like the
thing you might like and should come to
my conference and but do I definitely
check all of them are there lovely
places they're a great excuse to travel
with your partner but do check them all
out mean they're all worthwhile
definitely even though
yeah so we expect to have Paideia
Hamsterdam again this year and Paideia
Berlin and the US will likely have
phytate in New York again in the fall
we're probably gonna have our first time
played at La in the fall as well first
time in LA and looking to maybe do a PI
data DC also in the fall you can see
we're gonna probably do PI data Cordoba
and Warsaw again and many more so
continue to check PI data org and see as
the events get scheduled and we hope to
see you there for all those and the
other kind of event I also wanted to
mention as Gina did as well was the
different sprints and other kind of
opportunities that people can engage in
and actually want to invite mark up if
he's here and wanted to kind of talk
about the latest sprint that we did
because it was a pretty cool thing
yeah thanks everyone I don't know if you
saw that it was a bit quite a bit of a
big thing I would say like with what
they upon does a sprint it was a
worldwide event where 30 different
cities around 500 people were
contributing to two pandas dependence
documentation how many people was was
there worth participating I see just
like some hands yeah feel them that's
pretty cool and we managed to fix around
300 pandas documentation in the next
release you will see the results of that
is like when you hold two pandas
documentation is instead of having a
single line saying they had met or it on
the head of the data frame you will have
some sort of examples and things like
that I just want to show you a few
pictures I think that's better that was
from Nigeria from loggers that was in
Paris that was the group in Delhi they
did a lot of nice stuff on the on the
string functions that was in in Chicago
it was really an amazing experience I
think it's a really good thing to to go
from being a user of all these tools to
being a developer even if it's a very
small contribution something like a dog
thing actually I said it's a small but
in six hours very few people could
finish them and
actually it was much more were there not
at home if you're interested on that you
want to discover and you want to get
like become a pandas contributor and not
a pandas user
tomorrow we're running this this spring
it just like some introduction so if
it's something that scares you I think
it's worth worth taking the opportunity
to not feel as scary anymore and
understand that it's something really
really amazing to be part of yeah thank
you as I said that's about it
email me if you have any questions or
any requests and I'll see you at the
event thank you I would like to talk
about dirty categories so machine
learning basically models data as a
numerical matrices real life doesn't sad
cat the problem I'm interested in
specifically is this column here what do
we see we see things like overlapping
categories if you read those categories
you know that there is true information
between this in real life we will have
you know very high cardinality the
specific data set has 400 unique entries
and 10,000 rows with rare categories we
have only one architect three and what
happens if you have a new category in
the test set so this happens in many
data sets in the wild this is a plot
that shows the evolution of the number
of categories for a bunch of different
data sets where the number of rows so
basically to go up
the graph shows it on the scientist so
our goal is to do supervised learning on
thirty categories and the intuition
behind this is that we shouldn't
generate their states at because this is
the statistical question should inform
the curation basically I have a data set
where I have those two corporations are
they the same yes/no is this you know
morphological variant yes though so
there's a bunch of different related
approaches and database cleaning people
will call this a deduplication record
linkage problem in natural language
processing we'll look at this as a
semantic problem this is not something
word vectors will capture on Wikipedia
by the way and in in machine learning
there is a bunch of different problems
related and I mean I'd like to connect
to cat boost which is a fantastic
library that has related solutions to
what we do I mean only related so what
what we're proposing is to look at the
to adapt one hot encoding to look at the
similarities between strings okay and
we've we've worked at this on a
submitted academic paper where we're
looking at a bunch of things and there's
going to be more work throughout it cold
and so rainy the idea is you look at one
Hunton coding but instead of putting
ones and zeros you're going to put a
similarity okay
and this doesn't solve everything
because you still get a matrix that that
tends to grow and you need to compute
this fast but we're working on this and
all these problems are solvable so one
of the problems is the dimensionality
that increases so basically you can do
things that are related to random
projections to make this not grow and
limit the dimensionality and or you can
you know take in your dictionary only
the most frequent categories there are
different ways of doing this so what
we're going to be working on next is
using a trick that's known as hashing
which is a common trick when you're
trying to count things and specifically
hashing engrams
to basically do random projection with
speed all right this is all nice and
good so my goal here is to tell you that
dirty categories are a thing that we
should be doing statistical modeling on
non curated dirty categories
I want you to give me your dirty data
because I want to include it in my
benchmarks we're proposing a simple
solution that's called similarity
encoding and we're proposing software
which is research software right
it is not production software but that
you can try and contribute to and that's
all hip thank you
my name is dr the contest e and i'm one
of the ten organizers of the Panda
fantastic by the item a you're committed
and just in case today or tomorrow or in
the future you want to start a new PI
data meetup let me give you my personal
recommendation first one please do not
worry if you are a beginner in that in
data analysis so it's not necessary to
be a great expert to start a meetup so
keep that in mind
second remember that you will be a
volunteer and that means that instead of
watching the last episode of Game of
Thrones you will be preparing warring
and organizing your nets event keep that
in mind too do not forget about
networking networking is the key of the
success of you of the your Meetup
why because networking will allow you to
find organizers to find speakers
sponsors members volunteers so you have
to work with networking organization is
easier if you are not alone so first
task look for other organizers to help
you with the wisdom in table and that's
very common most of your members won't
know anything or very little about data
analysis so expect to teach them the
basics okay and the most important one
enjoyed this perience it's a great great
experience
and learned from it you will learn a lot
how to organize events and you will
learn a lot about data analysis too and
well that's all
that's my Meetup I hope you can go to my
York on Sunday and give us a talk or
attend our Meetup thank you very much
hi everyone my name is Tina I mean a
scientist working and I just thought
that this would be a nice place to share
some observations about a little
simulation study that I've done and it's
bad model consistency and something
quite boring which is different versions
so I'd like to start just out of
interest
who knows what from the top of their
head what model version they're
currently using in the library so say SK
learn or h2o or whatever your preferred
thing is it's a few hands next question
would be who if they update regularly
breeze reads the release history yeah
not so many hands and I think that's
quite natural and it kind of shows the
comfortable position that we're in
because we have wonderful people
developing all this cool stuff and
making it available for us free of
charge but it's also there is a risk
behind it so what if you upgrade and
suddenly your model results change and I
was recently in the position so I just
reread some older code and nothing had
changed not the data or not the script
nothing but my model had results had
changed so I got kind of interested in
this slightly hygiene kind of aspect
because yeah there's a lot of developers
who focus on efficiency and I wanted to
know how much of model consistency are
we actually sacrificing maybe for some
model efficiency steps so I did a little
simulation study because that's easy to
do you just take all the so here I've
taken gradient boosting
and I've looked I've basically taken all
of the versions that you've got and you
have a little script which loops through
all the versions and whenever they
install you run a baseline gradient
boosting model for scikit-learn extra
boost a GBM by GBM h2o and cut boost so
those are the most popular ones which I
guess most of us are using at some point
and then I just compared the variants of
the estimates of that default model so I
didn't actually invest any time in
tuning the models but that's not
necessary for showing the point here so
if we are just looking at comparing the
classification results and regression
results I'd compared mean absolute error
for the regression case and f1 score
because that's easiest and implemented
everywhere and if you just look at oh
you can't see anything so here you see
how the model evaluation changes as you
change the version as you see it's a
quite stable picture however yeah you
see some some indications that for like
GBM there's something going on and for
Escalona something on so let's look into
the actual underlying data points which
are this so here you see the regression
results mean absolute error and you see
each package and I'm just looping
through all of the versions and I'm
plotting the accuracy mean absolute
error here f1 score here and yeah what
do you see so you see for the regression
case SK learn and execute boost is best
kept boost not so well for some reason
but I wouldn't over interpret these
results because these are just default
models and I'm really interested in if I
changed nothing so other things being
equal how consistent are my results and
you see the same for the f1 score and
something very interesting is that
there's something going on with like GBM
and that's also the package where I
found some differences and I was not the
only one I found a lot of github
comments I found a lot of comments on
Google so if we zoom in here with now on
the x-axis you actually see it's what
the each of the versions were and so for
the classification case there's
something going on where the eff ones go
drastically improves between version 2.0
four and 2.0 five and then it drops
again and then it increases again you
kind of see this similar development for
the regression case and yeah I just got
interested in what's going on here I
really like the package I have to say
it's it's extremely fast it's very
scalable and I do want to use it but as
user have to understand these things so
I had a I got interested and I actually
did a little bit of detective work and
on the github commits there were two
reasons that they were investigating one
is the treatment of n/a variables so in
one version it was treated as zero and
the other one it was treated as a
separate category model completely
separate so I tested that but that
doesn't make any difference so that's
not it and then there were also some
comments about the max pin and how that
is treated in the algorithm and there
were actually quite some substantial
changes which were moved out of the
Python process into a seed pre-post is a
header file so it's a considerable
change and the execution and I think
just this is kind of an example of one
of the yeah where we should refocus on
this testing so somebody's made some
good development but how do we test it
and this quality insurance as we have
brilliant open source development but we
also want variant open source
development testing and I'm kind of
proposing here well why can't we not why
do we have to write all of our tests
ourselves why do we not have an open
source benchmarking environment for
testing all the performance against the
same data set
and not just IRAs or Boston house house
pricing which are very correlated data
sets but why don't we have an
open-source development for continuous
testing where each deployment can be
tested against the same benchmarks I
think that would save time on testing so
each of the developers don't have to do
that themselves
so it would speed up development and I
think it would also help the spread the
usage of open source packages and
enterprise so yeah thanks
so the price I'm a master's student at
Warwick University so I'm going to talk
about my dissertation which has the
title detecting and clustering facts
checkable claims so some of you who
enter let's talk this so those of you
that went to let's talk this morning you
might be thinking that that looks quite
similar and that's because it is left's
my supervisor so hopefully yeah
hopefully I can bring some stuff that I
wasn't in let's talk and provide some
more more information for you so it's in
collaboration with full facts which is
where lab works and full facts are one
of the UK's leading fact-checking
charities and their job is is to
essentially take claims that are made on
television in debates and on the radio
by politicians and other other sort of
influential figures and check the facts
behind those claims to make sure that
the general public are well informed
about what they're reading and listening
to and hearing and that's really really
important because you know otherwise the
spread of misinformation ends up
happening and going around the general
public and when the general public are
misinformed they make misinformed
political decisions and that kind of
messes with democracy somewhat so it's
really really important the work that
four-factor doing and I've become really
passionate about it since doing this
dissertation so I've mentioned claim but
what actually is a claim here are some
examples so unemployment dropped by 2%
last year that is a claim someone's
claiming something and the fact can be
checked relatively easily under the
Conservatives
nurses us an all-time high again it's
the same as the previous one the lady
would like to ask a question now this is
kind of a tricky one so it's actually is
a claim but in the context of
fact-checking it's not a claim you can't
check the facts behind that but
grammatically and semantically it's it's
similar to the FIR the first two
examples I gave and the other one is it
is my opinion that immigration is bad
for the economy that that's someone's
opinion by the way it's not my opinion
that is someone's opinion it's not a
claim so in order to do the
fact-checking as a clear process it's
it's obviously a claim has to be
identified first and foremost otherwise
you can't fact check anything the type
of claim needs to be be found so they
know where to look when doing the
fact-checking and then you need to
identify the popular claims so that you
know which ones should be fact checked
and then once this is done the the facts
are checked and a really detailed report
is put online for the public so this box
here is is my project and I'm looking to
automate though the sort of pre chat pre
fact-checking process there so this is
the overview of the methodologies are
going to be identifying claims binary
classification then there's going to be
a multi-class classification of the type
of claim and then we're going to be
using clustering and power phrasing
techniques to find out the most popular
claims as well so the progress I've made
so far is is purely on the claim
detection side of things so here's some
results we use stratified k 10-fold
cross-validation on all of these so yeah
just a variety they're just various
they're logistic regressions tf-idf and
we've used embeddings as a transfer
learning fast because we've got a quite
small dataset there's only about 4,000
sentences these results were okay
they're not bad but the best results so
far has come from a method called
inverse sent which lev presented this
morning in detail but essentially it's a
word embeddings you generated using
natural language inference task insider
by LST mu or net and we needs a really
good results 92 precision in 87 recall
after ghostgirls talk yesterday we went
back another another look at it and
actually turns out that this is this
five percent either side of the recall
so it's not always 87 it can be less or
more
and 2% other side of precision so what's
next that's what we've done so far
up next is going to be basically finding
out these popular claims and we're going
to use them normal power freeze
detection techniques and basically form
clusters of similar phrases which are
the popular claims because they appear
more often than anything else thank you
very much I wanted to talk briefly about
something I did to share maybe someone
else also will have benefit from using
that I wanted to experiment with those
word embeddings you hear about because
yeah like the ideas that I had involved
small datasets just like Oliver was
saying before me and India like you can
like you can read and basically when you
browse the internet to look for
pre-trained word embeddings you can find
many generous companies and people post
their stuff and for example fast text
when I go too fast X I I can go to
download models and then they have word
vectors for many languages and and when
I want to use that it essentially it
turns out to be a very long file with
the word and and the vector and if I
want to load that Python either I have
to read the whole thing or I have to
load it into one of the models like for
example fast X exposed they have they
have Python bindings for for their
further yeah for the solution so if I
use that sorry import fast X and I want
to I wanted to show you that I
downloaded the model earlier and I had
the zip file has is 500 megabytes and
the unpacked thing is 2 gigabytes so
it's quite a large thing and then if I
want to do more
equals fast text load model and then I
I'm gonna give the password back and
then then what I'm gonna see is I'm
gonna see this dreaded star here for
nearly forever and then if I go to
Activity Monitor I'm gonna see an
ever-growing memory consumption
situation regarding loading this file
and I tried it earlier this week and it
ballooned to 40 gigs and then I just had
to kill it so I can like let it run and
so I did I developed something that
basically takes other people's work and
package is nicely to solve this thing
and I post posted it and yeah good hub
and this is essentially like word
embeddings our keys map to values so I
use level DB as a disk based yeah key
value storage and and yeah and just like
the Python binding developed by a
gentleman from the Netherlands who
generously also published this package
and it just wrapped it nicely so we can
download glove you can download whatever
else you can read a zip file and create
this level DB indexed database and then
just look it up as you please and stick
it into like a Keres layer or whatever
you're trying to do so
it's called M store so I'm just gonna do
import and store and then do e equals M
store and then just specify a path to
the place where I created this so again
home or to back and then ft wiki and
that's it and and it's open and then I
can do e and then like use what's my
favorite word like whatever cat and then
I have the embedding so it uses struct
can unpacked to make like the array of
floats into a very condensed bite
situation so just to save space as well
so the the leveldb
story is just as big as the zip file
initially so it just takes half a
gigabyte for this particular situation
and the way you create it is you can do
em store ok game over
you can just do em to create and it's
I'm gonna post and slack the github
address oh okay sorry good idea yeah so
these are weddings but yeah if you do
create embedding database you just you
just do the zip file origin and then the
destination where you want to write the
level DB database and it does it in like
for this for this file it does it didn't
have no it a minute and a half and then
you're good to go for every restart of
your curtain or whatever happens
something breaks you never have to wait
five minutes for the thing to load into
memory yeah it's I find it helpful it
doesn't do nearest neighbors but it does
reading fast so thank you very much and
[Applause]
hi I'm Nick Radcliffe this is gonna be
super fast you you all move to Python 3
anyway so it's irrelevant but in case
any of you haven't and happened to have
lots of code bases a couple of things we
learnt actually doing it we it was gonna
be called porting 140 thousand lines of
code from Python to to Python 3 but then
we looked in the subdirectories and who
knew there was a bit more so in case you
haven't heard it's even worse than we
thought it's dying on the 1st of January
not the not whatever date in April ever
an originally guessed we have our
commercial software mirror which is
turnstiles lines of code worse than that
it's not any Python - it's got utf-8 in
the middle not Unicode so things are
really really really bad or at least
they were our goal we decided slightly
suicidal it was to have a single code
base that would run in Python 2 in
Python 3 and not only that but it would
run in Python 2 with Unicode literals
all with bytes and without you managed
to do that which is pretty fantastic
which means we can start ripping out all
this
now I would say the most important thing
we had was big set of tests we had about
1600 tests with about 10,000 assertions
in them so that was a pretty good start
so we tended to know whether things
worked basically none of them worked as
soon as we shoved it into Python 3 first
thing we did was put all the future
imports except the unicode one in and
that's obviously a good start we have
the division one there anyway but that
bloody print function and stuff
we need to sort out we had a we had code
toggle whether or not we were using
Unicode literals and that was really the
first thing we tackle trying to make
that work that obviously is one of the
really hard bits in the Python 2/3
transition you discover lots of things
along the way you discover that Python 3
is much fussier about nulls and lists
non values in list and you have to get
rid of them you can't do comparisons
between null values and numbers in
Python 3 which is a really good thing
but if you've got code that does it you
need something like this some kind of
helper function so to deal with it we
have loads of declarations all over the
place that are checking whether we're
Python 2 or Python 3 and making
everything available in both so we need
the bytes type available we need the
Unicode type available and then we have
lots of functions for forcing things to
be either Unicode or utf-8 definitely
different types according to to what we
need them according to whether we're
doing i/o or not we have scatter I'm not
going to go through them in detail but
we have scads of functions to forcing
things to be into Unicode or into utf-8
or into whatever our native internal
implementation is or into whatever not
our internal implementation is it's all
very tedious so we have the types Long's
and in you have to worry about because
the long type goes away because inns are
Long's in Python 3
they've disarray I'm sounding like I'm
complaining but it's you know it's not
very annoying when you're doing the poor
turns out that things have moved in the
CGI and URL libraries that we use quite
a lot so you have to have conditional
imports for that tiny little things have
changed like when you print an escaped
string like a regular expression it
turns out you get an extra backslash in
Python 2 compared with python 3 who knew
who cares well it messes up
if you're testing that kind of stuff
one of the big things obviously you'll
know about is a lot of things that were
lists in Python 2 generators or
iterations of some sort in Python 3 and
that means that you in particular can't
loop over dictionaries and change the
contents as you're going which is always
kind of a dangerous thing to do anyway
but it doesn't work in Python 3 so the
quick hack is to lista fie lots of
things but the better thing obviously to
do is to actually benefit from the fact
you using generators if you possibly can
to avoid blowing them up numerical
precision has changed for printing in
Python 3 so again that'll screw up your
tests if you don't use it carefully for
minutes already the next method has gone
on iterator so you actually have to use
next on the iterator instead which is
fine but you have to do it
there are me variables yes one of the
really super annoying things in Python 2
is that if you use a dummy variable in a
comprehension it's still defined after
the thing so you can screw up real
variable starts go on in Python 3 which
is fantastic unless of course you
depended on the fact that you could
still read it afterwards pickles are not
really compatible between Python 2 and
Python 3 you shouldn't be using for
anything except very short-term storage
anyway but we were so we switched Jason
it turns out it's not only more portable
it's much faster as well so God knows
why we weren't doing that anyway last
couple of comments we in doing this
didn't use many of the conversion tools
but we did use PAP eight and pi flakes
and our very own tdj library for
checking an awful lot of stuff we use
pilant and coverage dot pi a little bit
for checking things we large-scale we
didn't find six or two to three helped
us at all I'm not saying about just we
didn't use them these slides are
available there from the Admiral meetup
at that URL there that's me thank you
for your time hopefully that helps
coming
James you know you're up after this
right
hello everyone this is Amit and I'm
going to talk about yet another Python
conference so this so this is PI
Londinium which is happening this summer
from 8 to 10 June and for the support of
PSF and the tickets are ready for sale
and tickets are really cheap so if you
can effort pi/8 'you can really afford
this and it's for the community and so
all the money generated from the tickets
would go to PSF directly we got some
really amazing speakers now me the chair
of PSF the actors and danielle the cool
contributor to django yeah you have
already heard him the co-founder of
co-founder of pirate uh London and then
we have Victor Sina VC Python code
elihpa and here's the schedule if you
wanted to talk and then you already lost
the chance and the venue is lending
itself to the in the Bloomberg's office
mix out to them remote and that's it
thank you so this is my fifth year at Pi
Day to London
it's the fifth time I've been giving
lightning talks in front of all of you I
think so far it's been an absolutely
amazing event for those of you who don't
know me I'm James I'm gonna volunteer at
nom focus I've been volunteering with
nom focus for six years and I keep doing
it because it's worthwhile
having seen how well-run this event is
you would like to run a PI data Meetup
or conference in your own City or your
own locality please
come let us know what the numbers booth
come talk to me you can see this
conference is absolutely been fantastic
this year it gets better every single
year I think we should give the
organizers florian and marco recognition
as well as cecilia recognition for their
hard work here so let's give them a
round of applause
and for those of you who aren't from
London I would love to talk to you about
doing something like this where you're
from so come talk to me I'm James I'm
with gnome focus and let me get into my
lightning talk so my lightning talk I
didn't have a whole lot of time to
prepare this because I was preparing the
pub quiz which is coming up shortly
I ran the questions by a couple of
people and they're not too hard they
were really hard last year so I tried to
go a little bit easy on you but it's
kind of fun there would be some good
questions for the lightning talk I
wanted to talk to you about a pet that a
lot of people kind of missed and when I
talk to people about this prep they
don't quite get what it's all about this
is pet 551 it was put together by a
Steve dower
who's one of the chairs for PI data
Seattle and if you scroll to the very
bottom it's a very it's a fairly long
pet but it's pretty straightforward you
can see that I was marginally involved
in its development you can see my name
here all the way at the bottom let me
explain it to you and it's something
that's actually people look at this they
don't quite get it but if you explain it
the right way it makes sense this is
about adding certain features to the
Python interpreter namely security
transparency and security transparency
I'll give you a scenario where it'll
just make sense imagine you have either
some Windows machine or some docker
container running an application if it's
a docker container joining that
application is pid' one meaning there is
no need for anything else on that in
that container you don't need a Python
interpreter unless the application is
running Python you don't need a shell
you don't need a compiler you actually
have an environment where it which has
restricted computation you can't just
run arbitrary code in this environment
cuz you can strip it clean of everything
if it's a Windows machine you can go
even further because Windows has tools
like the Vice guard so you can't take a
Windows machine and just run an exe if
it's not signed if the Vice card is
enabled well imagine that this container
contains maybe a database or a data
source a very private dot and your fear
is that somebody might get into that
container or into that VM once you're
inside that VM they'll use Python if
there's a Python interpreter in that VM
to bring down malware and then start
exfiltrating data so you might have
financial data health data personnel
data that's very valuable there and if
there's a Python interpreter inside that
virtual machine or inside that container
it can be used as an exploit to pull
data out now one of the problems is if
you eliminate Python and you only run
compiled applications that's fine but we
using Python and the whole process for
compiling Python TX sees is kind of a
mess people have been trying this for a
long time but even with a production
pipeline
you know the deployment of it's kind of
messy so at 5:51 is the idea that you
can take a Python interpreter we can add
certain things to that interpreter to
not only lock it down but also to
provide security transparency so that if
you have a here's our slack channel so
that if you have a Python interpreter
that has no or I don't report you can at
least check to see what's going on
inside the interpreter you can add
logging hooks so that you can at least
see somebody's trying to break into this
machine or somebody's trying to use
Python on this machine to pull malware
in to exfiltrate data I one of the
things that I worked on for this is
trying to as a pep says I worked on some
of the initial implementation details
and then I thought wouldn't it be fun to
popularize this idea if anybody wants to
use it to see how I can break it so I
want to show you in the remaining minute
or two that I have one really neat thing
that we discovered in working through
this pet one problem is if you have code
signing if you have a Python interpreter
that can only run signed code and so
you're done if you don't have a signing
key to sign the code you can't run it in
the virtual machine but there are a
couple of very easy exploits if in one
of the previous talks Nick I believes
talked about not using pickle because
it's not stable between Python 2 and
Python 3 if you care about security
do not use pickle pickle basically opens
a hole in your Python interpreter to run
arbitrary code there are other ways to
get arbitrary code execution of Python
there's one thing that we found that was
very interesting what we found is when
you have something like a variable in
Python and you do something like x
equals 10 X plus 1 and you disassemble
it
you can see there's this load fast
operation this represents how Python
pulls in a local variable how it loads
of local very belong to its staff if you
look at the bytecode for it you can see
it calls this macro get local if you
look at this macro get local you can see
it does an array access that's unbounded
so what we developed or a couple of
techniques by which you can create
poisoned by codes that tell your load
fast to load a local variable that
doesn't actually exist so that you can
get unbounded memory access and your
Python interpreter once you have that
technique it becomes very easy to do
things one of the things that we're
working on right now is you might not be
able to write to an arbitrary location
because of memory protections for
example if you look at proc your proc
file system you can see that the way
that memory is orientated on Linux you
have these different pages representing
the different parts of your program you
can see here's the cat here's the Lib C
and some of these are marked as read or
write only and you might only be able to
reach into a read-only page and you
won't be able to write there but using
this technique what you can do is you
can start trying you can spawn Python
interpreters you can fork exec to spawn
child Python interpreters and just have
them read sequentially through memory
until they fail to start mapping out
what memory looks like you don't know
anything but but have the ability to run
Poisson bytecode through a Poisson
pickle object and you can start scanning
through memory once you do that you can
find a page that you can maybe write to
and what you can do with this is because
you can write 2 arbitrary parts of
memory and load them up we've already
been able to make tuples mutable that's
actually fairly easy I'll show you the
I'll show you the get the gist for it it
was actually fairly easy to make tuples
mutable and I have to a little hard to
get Joe's Twitter handle right but we'll
see where is it mutable tuple that's the
first thing and the second thing that
we're working on right now here's tuple
set item using this approach we create a
poison byte code and then a couple of
generators and in the end you end up
being able to change the contents of a
tuple by just writing directly to that
memory the other thing that we want to
do is we want to take
C extension in a string pull it into the
Python interpreter by writing it to
arbitrary memory locations and then lift
that into the interpreter by telling
Python it's an actual
Python object by loading into it using a
poisoned bytecode and Python doesn't
know are these valid Python objects that
I've been I've a located or not so you
can just take a string that contains
some some really nasty payload and do
that the reason for that is when Steve
was working on this he said you know I
can't get people interested in this can
you come up with a way to do a meltdown
or Specter hack using Python and this
pep and that's the best we can do so
hopefully by next year we'll have a
meltdown or Specter hack using Python on
a lockdown machine but I did want to
genuinely bring the attention of Pepsi
at 5:51 for you cuz if you work in a
healthcare company or a financial
services company you may actually have
machines which allow attackers to come
in bring malware in and start
exfiltrating data and in those cases you
know that's a quite quite a serious
problem
the use of Python there is actually
opening up a serious hole for you and so
hopefully you have a look at this pep
and if you'd like to talk about it or
like to talk about ways that you can
secure a Python interpreter in
production to avoid these please come to
see me thank you so much
[Applause]